hey guys it's Justine and today we're
unboxing the brand new Elite controller
for Xbox now this is a custom one so
before you're able to go into the design
lab and you can customize XBox
controllers but now you can actually
customize the elite controllers and I'm
so excited about this I already
obviously customized mine online ordered
it and it's here so let's open it up and
check it out
tools not only can you Custom Design the
actual controller but you can even
customize the paddles and the buttons as
well and the d-pad
my goodness I forgot what I made it look
like this looks so freaking freaky good
I mean if you're a fan of then you're
gonna love this if you're not a fan of
Pink well that's not my problem because
I am and look at this and we need to
zoom in we need to really get a good
look at it I also added a little
engraving here of my Xbox gamer tag the
elite controllers just it's so smooth so
freaking smooth
so good oh my gosh it turned out so
great and what I love about the elite
controller is you're able to add paddles
back here so I usually use that to
crouch to slide and depending upon the
game you can customize it to do really
whatever you want so this button right
here will let you adjust the trigger
tension so right now
it's long all the way I'm gonna switch
it to the short so this gives you an
advantage you don't have to press all
the way in
feels so good I can't wait to play Call
of Duty like I'm I'm just I'm so excited
all right let's open up the paddles here
oh oh look at him they're so pretty but
these were all add-ons in addition to
doing the controller so you obviously
don't have to get these but there was no
way I was making this beautiful custom
controller and not fully decking it out
look at that I can just pop this right
out
attach that we're ready to go here's our
different buttons
you just pulled it off that's it let's
look at that that's like a very long
joystick
to one of these I have one of these
to be honest with you I kind of just
like the ones that it came with so
that's probably what I'm going to be
using but I wanted to get this so that I
would be able to have the swappable
d-pad as well okay so here's the paddles
we're gonna put those on the back
so you're able to just use your fingers
like that I love this controller so much
so beautiful I'm so hyped about it I
can't wait to play Call of Duty
unfortunately I have to go to dinner so
I can't play tonight this weekend maybe
can I play this weekend I don't know
I've been so busy I don't like being
busy I like to just play video games
getting hyped for the holidays because
that's usually when me and my sister
just sit at home and play video games
all the time so my case hasn't come in
for this yet but I did get a custom case
for it
[Music]
and here it is this is the final look
the final Elite controller and if you
guys want to check this out I will put a
link in the description if you want to
check out the Xbox Design Lab you can
design one of the elite controllers or
you can just design one of the regular
controllers as well I'm so happy with
how this turned out it's really
beautiful well thank you guys so much
for watching let me know if you've ever
designed one of these custom controllers
if you have I would love to see them
please send me them on Twitter tweet me
at iJustine and send me your custom
controllers whether you've done it
recently or you've done it a long time
ago I'd love to see them don't forget to
like comment and subscribe and I'll see
you in the next video bye
[Music]
foreign